[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 47 of
GameSpot after dark I'm your host Jake
Decker and joining me this week is Kelly
plaguey Wow Mike oh hi I'm what up and
Jeff Bakalar how you doing what's going
on you guys thanks so much for having me
thank you for joining us we actually we
teased it last week and a lot of people
in our discord or a couple people in of
discord were like excited they're like
ooh Jeff Bakalar is coming on just -
that's just - yeah just I was - just the
- I miss you Jeff I see you once every
year every CNET party at CES is our time
together yeah I'm starting to realize we
don't see each other sober ever well I
see you on the stage and then I pile I
give you a nod or DAP you up and then
like I said we never see John well
actually no this is a podcast where we
drink alcohol so one day we'll get to
know each other as a sober people but
it's not the time for that drink
responsibly yes absolutely
anyway we start this show off with well
sometimes you start this trough with the
Chris from Dayton Ohio segment where we
basically introduce our guests so the
story behind this which I've said many
times and I'm sure listeners are tired
of it is that when we started this
podcast we did a couple episodes and
someone wrote in and was like I don't
know who the hell any of you are could
you tell us a bit about who you are what
kind of games you play what you do what
you like to do doesn't even have to be
games hobbies but if you like honestly
before you begin Jeff sorry there's a
little theme song that goes with the
Chris from Dayton Ohio segment I would
really just sing it for you that's a guy
that's it
I I think I've said it before but I
don't even think Chris listens to this
podcast anymore that's
yeah little did he know he started a
revolution prove me wrong if you're
still listening crisply missing so how
deep do you want me to go start from the
beginning where where were you born
tell us about Jersey tell us about the
swamps of Jersey whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I'm just swamps the swamp goblins
of Jersey oh the swamp goblins of course
yeah so my name is Jeff Bakalar I'm in
there at large for cnet.com which does a
lot of tech and industry news and I've
been there for a very very long time a
very long time tell us how long just
sorry I faced my own mortality right now
I'm just can I say that it's in double
digits yours you can't it's Michael
you'd be very correct in saying that
it's many double digit years but look
what are you gonna do right you love
where you works you stay there forever
if you can write that's her I started
off working there
doing like man I was doing like home
theater stuff and I moved around and
began covering video games like ten
years ago and I've been doing that ever
since
um and then I started a podcast there a
while back that ended and then I
switched into basically only doing video
like in front of the camera behind the
camera
strategy stuff like that I hold a
podcast on giantbomb called the giant
piece cast and yeah that's sort of my
deal where I want to tell people I cut
my titles at or large it's just so it's
it's dubious outlaw so cool I like that
description vigilante editor ah sure
sure let's go with that
but what it really means is I just have
my fingers and a lot of different pies
that's the one know
yours in like that okay
not to me it's not why you like hi no I
don't want I don't want [ __ ]
touching all my damn pies they're not
wrong you're not wrong like bad analogy
makes no sense on each one of your
fingers into it relax
what is that why what kind of situation
are you in anyway so yeah that's what
I've been doing for the for a little
over a decade and no III all kidding
aside I love to rag on seem it for some
reason but it's probably bad but I just
absolutely love the vast majority of the
people that I work with so that's it's a
great thing and I love and I love
GameSpot and I love Giant Bomb and I
love all the other brands what about
your gaming your gaming life
tell us about pinball oh my gosh so I've
always been a gigantic pinball
enthusiast and over the last two years
I've I've really dove in to the deep end
headfirst in a way that some would call
crazy but I mean I was I bought a house
finally I've moved out of the city and I
started a family and we have we have
enough room that I could get a couple
more machines I love pinball a lot and I
realized that that's a tough sell for a
lot of people and that's fine
but you know up until this lockdown our
retro arcade culture was a very big
thing I still believe it to be that
especially you know where I wherever I
travel I always find these like pop not
pop up but they're like pinball bars
arcade bars I mean you know what I'm
talking about you've been in places like
that and I love that scene I just love
being around that and now I'm starting
my own personal pinball collection I'm
starting to stream it on Twitch every
now and then that's been a lot of fun
ever since we've been you know sort of
held up in here and
yeah I'm super I'm super into that in
terms of like regular games I love all
video games I like I'll try anything
once
there's nothing I won't play or at least
give a shot I finished I just finished
last of us two for that review a couple
weeks ago so I'm done with games for the
year yeah yeah that's I don't really
like I don't really have you know I
tried to like narrow it down like what
is my like specific sort of track of
like taste and stuff like that and I
don't really think I have it like you
know when I was at more like nascent
sort of player I would I would like stay
away from RPGs for some reason just
because I was probably you know a big
idiot but but yeah there's nothing I
won't try I love I love weird stuff if
it's super weird I'm probably gonna like
it even if it's a bad game
I saw your uh your tweet with your kid
your son time over bug snacks and I was
that was very adorable but that that is
definitely a weird game I'm sure that's
something oh my god I was funny because
we I've just been messing around with
that on Twitter and we did a couple
before that we did it for the because my
son is like he's gotten into video games
obviously I mean this was not a this was
not a tough sell for him and I I
remember seeing that Unreal 5 like
trailer demo thing they did and I showed
my son it and he just started like
losing his he's like what is this where
I give this downloading can we play this
oh and I was like no you idiot like exam
in a game little kid it's it's just this
demo but he started talking so I just
literally slid this microphone in front
of his face made him watch it like five
times and then just like put it put
together the best what he said and
that's you know what we did with Mario
Paper Mario and and the books next thing
and it was very cool to see the the
developers like appreciate that I
thought that was awesome I thought it
was a thing for his TV the origins of
hot dog fingers that's it I mean I funny
like so he said that
and my wife was your - watching and we
were laughing so hard like listen with
headphones real close the audio just
like Joe falls off a cliff right after
that because it's just her and I losing
our mind it's a good time I'm glad to
bring it back a little you mentioned
you've been streaming pinball I just out
of curiosity like what what goes into
that you just set up a camera in your
pinball area I guess and yeah I mean
these regular streamers they don't know
how good they have it us pinball say
because that seems way more work than
install extremely me at least the two
cam setup right it is absolutely way
harder I had no idea what I was getting
myself into I just you know my wife's in
production over the years we've
collected many many cameras and sort of
miscellaneous like you know stuff around
the house tripods you know just like old
GoPros that like what the hell are you
gonna use a GoPro to for like ever again
right so there's this dude who streams
called dead flip who I kind of became
friendly with over the over the last
like year or so I met up with him at CES
I've been following like a lot of the
stuff that he's been doing and he as far
as I understand it I sort of like paved
the way for for how pinball streaming
has sort of come up and I really just
took a lot of advice from him and yeah I
have like four cameras all going at once
I mean you know in you in obviously you
know look look a lot of it is self you
know it's very intuitive and you can
kind of figure out like you know what
you need to do but you know OBS is an
amazing piece of software and a lot of
trial and error and you know just like
getting like you know cuz pinball is
like this real life kind of you know
analog kinetic thing and you know you
want to have like 60 frames per second
on the camera using to show that play
field so like getting it all right and
all the yeah it takes forever to set it
up I have a couple tables in my house
and I was like I was like man I don't
even want to switch locations because
just having to do that is such a huge
pain in the ass it takes like hours I
said Oh up
but I'm happy to do it it's so much fun
and I feel like not a lot of people are
doing it so it was a really like no you
know kind of no-brainer for me to
introduce people and do a thing that I
that I love so much
yeah that's that's pretty cool like I
think that kind of stuff is the most
interesting on Twitch to like everyone
streams games at this point right but
whenever you see something like pinball
or I don't know just some of the weirder
games or ideas that stuff always is so
much more interesting at least to me but
what do I know
no like the first like you know it was
always like a thing where I was like man
I wish people could like watch people
play pinball and I'm like oh you just I
I invented this in my head but like of
course someone is doing this of course
people are doing this so it was
definitely like very gratifying to see
not just people and many people are
doing it but like the community and
seeing how cool everyone you know inside
that is and it's been a really awesome
experience for sure
so yeah that's great should we move on
to what we've been playing or doing it
looks like we all we all got games here
we've got some games bro got some games
I figure I'll go last
cuz it's a big one yeah it's the big one
like Kelly do you want to start us off
here sure we talked about a little bit
last week but I have been playing the
Pokemon sorting shield DLC I love armor
and you know I've had much more time
since last week to actually like the
into it because it came out the day that
we recorded last week so they're just
like some cool quality of life things
and you know me I'm really gonna get
really focused on the quality life stuff
with Pokemon but it really does improve
the quality of my life so the first one
is you can find so many more items on
the island of armor it's so generous I
don't know if you've noticed this Jake
but you can get myths like nature
changing mints like just find them on
the ground and you can find the feathers
that are lay
they give you one Eevee which is really
good for fine-tuning an Eevee spread
when you're training a Pokemon I know
that probably sounds like gibberish just
some people um but you can find them
pretty liberally throughout the map so
um oh and the one thing I didn't tell
you this yet Jake but I I like didn't
believe it happened I found a flame orb
on the grounds oh really I was like so
much time yeah for the freaking flame
orb yeah how many times did you do the
Elite Four probably err not really great
one like I don't know at least 200 times
I did it enough times to completely hid
the money ceiling I hid the money
ceiling and I couldn't earn any more
money that's how many times I did those
battles um for a flame orb I don't I
never got it from that I had to trade
with somebody I just I it was like the
that tweet that was like I've been
reporting on the story for years and he
just tweeted it out that's how I felt or
I could literally I didn't believe it
happened so I hit the like 30-second
recording thing on my switch to like
check the footage and see if it was a
flame work so anyway that stuff is
really cool I've been very grateful
there is a person you can talk to who
will clear your pokemons v's which is
really great because you can do that
with berries but they're really they
were hard to get and you had to kind of
farm specific trees and I would do that
every single day farm those same trees
and I would only have enough berries
like if I make a couple mistakes EB
training the Pokemon so be able to pay
somebody in the game to do that for you
is awesome
and there's this like a little like
Diglett kind of it's not a mini game
it's more of like a side activity where
you can find 150 Diglett across the map
and I've been finding that really fun
actually cuz they're like it's a lowland
diglettz they have these like three
little hairs that stick up out of the
ground they're really cute and you click
on them and they come up and they're
like oh they do some stiglitz [ __ ] and
then you
you get you get Pokemon one as a reward
one of them is a regular slowpoke not a
Clarion slip hook that has a king's Rock
which is used to evolve
slowpoke so to get a slope King and that
should be really good roars did you get
the vending machines that sell all those
nutrients for Half Price cuz I thought
that was pretty cool yeah but there's a
lot of little things like that but I
think kind of they're the final tweaks
that I that make a lot of the
competitive stuff really accessible and
those final things would be items like
the flame more of items like protein
iron calcium any like Eevee related
stuff that's all present here and there
I think it's part of the update that was
released along with the DLC I don't know
if it's part of the DLC but they
upgraded the stat screen within the
Pokemon boxes so when you're scrolling
and you're trying to look at pokemons
IDs on the side it also displays their
ability in nature which was super
annoying you have to click between both
screens just to see like okay this
Pokemon is perfect stats but HUD doesn't
have the right everything else so they
they made the UI make more sense and
just a little like I appreciate little
things like that
I think Tori front it's like pretty slim
I'm really excited for the crown Tundra
DLC because I think that's gonna add
like more for what we've seen so far it
seems to have more like puzzle elements
from old Pokemon games that have kind of
gone missing in recent generations but
dungeon exploration really intrigues me
but I've really liked style of armor so
far it's nice to just have more Pokemon
to collect I kind of forgot how much I
do enjoy that aspect of Pokemon even
though I'm so deeply invested in
competitive Pokemon I'd the simple
things do delight me so oh and the
outfits are so good the outfits are
great fashion fits well you can dress
like Marty you got like the cute little
but it's better for girls probably like
a girl outfits are always gonna be cuter
but the I like the dojo uniform maybe
you want to go back to martial arts the
music
got any type of the music it is hard to
explain it's a cool remix of that one
vaguely racist tune these people need
the music I guess it's like really not
my place that's my quick take you're
gonna it was a really harrowing weekend
for me very hectic lots going on so I'm
a little behind it'll probably be up by
the time this podcast goes up unless I
like dice already happen I imagine
Michael Jeff you guys probably don't
have a whole lot to add on Pokemon but
you know the floor is open it's good
it's good to hear it's good to hear like
Callie's got more Pokemon to play I know
I know that [ __ ] makes you happy and
that makes a lot of other people happy
so I'm happy to hear that it is bringing
you joy in this these trying times and
that's really important sure echo all of
that without a doubt I've spats it's
beautiful it's a beautiful thing for
Gian pieces
oh good transition hmm oh boy I got some
[ __ ] to get off my chest I floors okay I
mean you know it's a that's a fair
question yeah yeah right now and like
the games that I've been playing have
been kind of a reflection of that
in many ways so persona 4 golden had
come out since last time I've been on
the podcast I've been playing it because
persona 4 golden was my favorite game of
all time up until I played finished and
reviewed persona 5 royal so it's 1 and 2
or 1a and 1b I would say answers my
favorite games of all time but I'm
playing replaying p4g since it came out
on PC it is
to have this game on not a Vita or PS TV
it's an emotional experience it's like
reliving those memories from like a
couple years ago three years ago when I
played it but that game means means so
much to me just like seeing being back
in ena ba where did it takes place and
being with those characters again is
it's like a like it's like a cozy
blanket for me and the origins of Chi I
sought to knock a man that's that's my
girl no matter what 100 and I tweeted
this out but my love for Chie has
nothing to do with like that waifu [ __ ]
that everyone like best girl whatever
like i I'm engaged in those discussions
but the thing about Chie is that she's
she's who I aspire to be in terms like
how much she whoops ass how much she
loves her friends and the fact that
she's like very adorable while doing all
of that that's my girl and so it's just
damn and Erin Fitzgerald is my favorite
voice actor of all time she's absolutely
wonderful and captures the spirit of her
character so well so persona 4 golden
has been great because sorry she didn't
voice the original HEA though right yeah
you're right voice actor and the PS yeah
- yes it's kind of cool that like so
many people were able to I don't know
connect with her as the new Chie because
I feel like that could go very wrong
yeah that's that's right but yeah she's
really embodied that character because
there's a million games that came out
after persona 4 with brizola 4 in it and
even in anime so Erin Fitzgerald is
really captured Chie so but the thing
though is I'm not that far in yet in the
grand scheme of things but the thing
that I'm keeping in mind is that when I
played persona 4 golden in 2017 I was
you know aware of the conversations
around how it handles LGBTQ issues as
I'm replaying it now as you get more and
more into the game those things begin to
unfold and reveal themselves more and
more but having played that three years
ago it's not the story beats that touch
on those things aren't exactly fresh in
my mind but I'm
extra conscious of it now so when I get
to those things I can be a lot more
critical of them than I was back then
and in a way I'm kind of like I'm not
scared but I am kind of I'm preparing
myself for disappointment because of how
much I've liked I've held persona for so
dear to me but now that I am I've
learned so in three years I've learned
so much more about like about LGBTQ
issues
what transphobia looks like what
transphobia sounds like when people talk
about what homophobia actually is how
that manifests in language how how
people talk to each other in relation to
those two those issues and how it gets
represented in media so that's and I
think that it's important I say this in
my my 10 year write up that I actually
wrote two years ago for persona 4 that
we should become no matter how much we
love something we should be critical of
the things that we love especially as it
relates to entertainment and media and
that's something I'm keeping in mind and
even like when I wrote that in 2018 I
didn't know as much as I do now
so that's gonna be an experience but and
well this is actually a question that
we'll get into later but the soundtrack
that game is it brings tears to my eyes
to hear that soundtrack again it's
absolutely beautiful some real j-pop and
jerry' I mean a lot of people who was
probably listen to the podcast know
about persona 4 very well maybe even
engaged in the persona 4 endurance run
from all those years back on giantbomb
calm I know I did so that was kind of
like where that back that love came from
I guess but yeah it's I've been going
through it and rizona 4 has been there
with me so yeah I am gonna keep playing
it because it brings me happiness but
also I need to see it through
just to recontextualize what that game
is with how I feel and what I know now
it's important thing to keep in mind
where does a lot of that stuff kind of
occur in the story it's just like kanji
right yeah and like some of your skates
later yeah so the way
I think kanji is one of the most
important characters to me because he
also represents a lot of a lot of I see
a lot of myself in him and I when I
actually tried explaining why kanji
means so much to me to somebody else and
I started like [ __ ] bursting out in
tears
it was [ __ ] wild yeah because like
because the thing is like kanji like as
hard as [ __ ] like I'll beat you ass
mother [ __ ] you if you you try and like
I don't know terrorize my friends or if
you try and like try and Punk my mom out
of money at her shop I'll beat your
[ __ ] ass then there's with a
folding chair yeah so I'm like that's my
guy but the thing is like he's he's very
I would say like he's like emotionally
like sensitive to things but he's also
like not sure of himself he loves
stuffed animals he likes cute [ __ ] I'm
like dog like this thing oh my gosh it's
like a life stuffed animal right yeah
it's alive its alive sleepy yeah so yeah
anybody's a so the thing is like how the
game frames him as easy gay is he not
gay is that even like what they're
trying to go for those are the things
that I'm conscious of and then how
Yosuke talks to him because Yosuke is a
piece of [ __ ] he's like a bro he's
supposed to be your bro and he's cool at
times but man that guy says some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and like if I recall correctly
he kind of gets away with it and I don't
know how I feel about that and then with
natto in terms of how it frames her
gender identity because at first when I
played it I took Naoto story as
workplace gender discrimination and it's
actually like addressing now it was very
complicated because [ __ ] it's yeah it's
it's it's coded and a lot of or a can
full unfold and a lot of transphobic
language depending on how you take her
social linked route but also like it's
it's hard because I think canonically
Naoto it identifies as
she and her but at first everyone
perceives Naoto as he him and that is
kind of the story progression and it's
kind of rooted in oh now I was trying to
be a detective but in these agencies
they discriminate against women so now
tell identifies as he him in order to
overcome that I think that's that's at
least how I remember it
but that is a very complicated thing to
communicate in a story and very easy to
[ __ ] up especially in a game that came
out in 2008 so you know it's interesting
I really like what you said if I like
being critical things we love I think
it's also interesting to think about a
context when it was released not in a
way to excuse it but in how something
might have been meaningful to you back
then and how you've grown since so an
example talking about like how
somebody's perceived as the anime Ouran
High School Host Club I know a lot of
people who really love that show it's
stars a character who was basically
non-binary and it came out I think in
2006 um and you know it's not like if
you look at it it's kind of problematic
because it's about like okay here's a
character who's assigned female at Birth
who doesn't really is like I don't care
about gender at all then gets recruited
by this host club and has to act like a
boy in order to like pay back a debt and
stuff it's some anime [ __ ] but like
I think at the time like I know a lot of
people who really loved how D the main
character because having like a
character that was like I have no
connection to my gender whatsoever it's
just something you didn't see but at the
same time that show includes like but
the the English subtitled version at
least includes like the T slur and like
really problematic things so it's
watching it now is a very different
experience that it wasn't watching it in
2006 and I just find that like it's
really it's cool when you're going back
to something you
to be able to reflect on it's not about
like oh I hate the thing I loved now
it's kind of about like oh how far I've
come from what I was when I first
encountered this thing so I really like
what you said about that sure yeah yeah
but and yeah I I think that's that's as
much as I have to say but one thing I I
don't want to use it as an excuse to be
like oh it came out in 2008 but it
definitely is that is something that you
need that is important to you keep in
mind when we are critiquing things that
are that are older like it's almost a
and I almost feel like it's hand wavy to
say that oh but it came out in 2008 yeah
but at the same time it's like in 2008
to have a JRPG that went for it like
this game went for it and looking back
now it failed on many levels but in a
way it's like but they went for it and
that's that's the thing I'm wrestling
with yeah like not about excusing it
it's just about like Mele there's a lot
of nuance to explore there yeah
definitely but if want to close the book
on p4g for now there's another older um
boom I look I'm playing old games man
good I think I'll try and get through
this one quickly but Deus Ex the
original that came out in 2000 he's a
[ __ ] a wild game to play in the year
of our Lord 2020 holy [ __ ] because if
you're a Jeff you're old you probably
played original Deus Ex I'm actually I'm
the second oldest one on this podcast so
I are the old ones and I played the
original Deus Ex yeah I had already
graduated I was out of college for
fifteen years when that game came out as
well man you look good for 60 I played
that in college though dates me but yeah
yeah I played that in like sixth grade
but oh that's cool two thousand thousand
I just started college in 2000 no yeah
yeah I graduate high school and do that
look I've come to accept it just like
times a flat circle yeah 41 I'm 40 then
you guys don't have to talk to me
anymore we had we had Khalifa Adams on
here that fool is 41 but yeah and we
rock with old people so I'll get hello
it's fine
but Deus Ex is is [ __ ] why let me
just try and if y'all don't know the
original Deus Ex so there is a pandemic
that hits the United States of America
there's people are dying in the streets
because of a plague there's a supposedly
a cure that the government has that has
created and is actually in control of
and you play as a special agent cop who
is supposed to not crack down on NSF
terrorists which is like a rogue militia
within the United States that have that
are perceived as like anarchists or like
hardcore like left-wing extremists and
as the story progresses I mean spoilers
for a 20 year old game but at a point
but your brother is also a also a
special special agent from único that's
the organization that you're working for
it's like top level [ __ ] law law
enforcement type [ __ ] and then and like
it's it's it's so it's a it's my first
introduction to cyberpunk to because
it's it's rooted inside of people's
introduction to side especially in the
video game form it's a first-person
immersive sim and if you track its
history war inspector Harvey Smith who's
now arcane doing dishonored and prey and
things like that and System Shock before
that so that's it was kind of the
pinnacle of that lineage in many ways
but yeah that game is while to play
because it's
rooted in how a pandemic is leveraged by
the rich and powerful to suppress people
and stay in power but it's also about
how capitalistic systems are in place to
not only suppress people but it's the
like body augmentations are kind of
supposed to be this great equalizer but
it's really not so it touches on a lot
of different topics of course a 20 year
old game it isn't exactly nuanced but
replaying it
Fayed's they hit some themes pretty
[ __ ] hard like their lines of
dialogue like it's it's almost comedic
now playing it because the voice acting
is like it's so bad it's good but some
of the lines on there are like oh [ __ ]
like they said they said some [ __ ] like
especially in the first mission when you
meet up with like the terrorist leader
you know you can kill him but the best
way to go about is to talk to him and
he'll tell you like yo he sounds like a
conspiracy theorist at first but then
he's like yo gayben this year taxes
didn't had this effect and then now rich
people don't pay as many taxes and then
now it's all leverage
it's like thrust down on the downtrodden
the people who face the consequences of
an extremely capitalistic system that's
exploited it's [ __ ] wild and yeah I'm
going through that game very conscious
of that as well
not so much in like I'm trying to
critique it in a way but I'm trying to
see like no I don't want to say how far
it's come because capitalism and
oppression are as old as time it's just
that in video game form this is what we
had in that year and it still resonates
in many ways and in light of cyberpunk
2077 I'm very conscious of that as I'm
seeing that game unfold as well because
not to say that like oh it needs to live
up to deus ex the original but if Deus
Ex touched on those themes and sometimes
quite nuanced ways especially on how it
frames capitalism and how it shows
police brutality as a mechanism to
enforce capitalism by the rich and
powerful
I expect cyberpunk 27 to go [ __ ] ham
on that [ __ ]
otherwise I'll be mad at supporting it
right it feels like that's what we're
set up for
yeah yeah that's been done for a little
bit but like yeah but I mean and also
yeah that's the route I'm sorry to
interrupt I feel like you're I feel like
you're playing a game of like going
through the archives of like dystopian
sci-fi and you could start to play this
game where it's like oh is this worse
than are you okay like I feel like I do
that with film a lot like now like the
next and the queue is like is children
of men actually worse than what we're
going through
yeah and right and like I just feel like
this is a very slippery slope of
oppression that you can enter doing that
kind of exercise but yeah very
interesting to hear someone look at a 20
year old game through the lens of 2020
that's that's pretty well how does it
perform like what you're playing on PC
oh yeah yeah I play on PC and because it
was an old Unreal Engine game it's very
easy to get modded yeah so I'm running
ultra-wide 21 by nine screen and you
just go into the ini file and then you
custom set the resolution and you custom
set the fov and there's like texture and
lighting mods that you add to it so not
it doesn't look like a modern game but
it looks clean and the fact that you can
modify and play with it like that it it
makes it a lot easier on the eyes I
always enjoyed that games atmosphere
that's that's them one thing to me is
it's it's a fit it all takes place at
night it's dark as hell like it's just
it's just a very like dark lighted game
but and it could obscure a lot of those
blemishes in a very old engine but it
has such a strong sense of like not just
the neon lights but the way the
characters are designed even though
they're like super old-ass character
models and also the music and the
ambient sounds are it's it really it it
mails a certain type of atmosphere that
I associate with cyberpunk so much
because this could just be the marketing
I'm Jake's gonna get into this of course
and much greater detail with Tyrell
cyberpunk 27
but in a way I think Erica or a hack had
kind of I can't remember if it was her
that coined the term cyber pop I seen
her threads on her threads on the
cyberpunk is a genre are really
fascinating I don't know about cyber pop
specifically but yeah but I came across
that term for her from her and it's kind
of like the celebration or the the
embracing of the cool-looking things of
cyberpunk cyberpunk without the critical
analysis I'm not saying that 2077 is
going to ignore that because we haven't
I haven't played the game it's a hundred
hour game but it's not not out yet but I
am expecting that because this it's
using the cyberpunk name and cyberpunk
as a genre as a concept is rooted in
dystopian like life and sure the
oppression of capitalistic system I mean
I will say just just to cut in like I
did play some cyberpunk but this is not
based on what I played but like you
could say the same things about fantasy
in a sense and CD Projekt RED did a very
good job of deconstructing that genre
with The Witcher games or three yeah
Witcher so I personally have faith that
they'll be capable of doing that but
once again like I played about four
hours I did not get much of the writing
considering how big that game is of
course we just messed around but we can
talk about that later the one thing I do
want to point out to you is that the
cyberpunk name for 2077 comes from
cyberpunk 2020 so specifically it is my
consonants universe of cyberpunk so I
think there's gonna be people conflating
cyberpunk as it originated with my pond
Smith with cyberpunk as an overall genre
and how its evolved um so there's I
think there's gonna be an interesting
dynamic there because you know like Jake
said they could take it they could
deconstruct the genre or they could take
it in a direction that's different
obviously the game from the marketing
we've seen like the the random Japanese
and like the neon and that kind of like
the the aggressive yeah the aggressive
Latino character that's been front and
center
all right I see what y'all which I'll
think of brown people but but I
yeah I do you think there's something to
be said for this game because Mike Pond
Smith himself is specifically involved
as a consultant on the game so I think
there's a bit of a complicated like
mm-hmm two versions of the word
cyberpunk same guy yeah - this IRA funk
I do want to hear what hard spaceship
breaker is yeah it's tough - first a
tough act to follow
oh my god no um so have you guys talked
about it or seen it or what do you know
about it it's the first time I'm seeing
this topic actually this game I got
turned on to it having someone on the
beast guys talk about it last week it is
very much like man it is like this weird
sort of like cowboy astronaut like miner
simulator where you you play as someone
it's you know obviously very far into
the future and you play someone who is
basically dismantling and cashing in the
scrap of like disused spacecrafts and
whatnot that is just sort of floating in
orbit outside of Earth I only got to
play for a few hours but it definitely
has this sort of like you know almost
like freelance you know for hire like
western cowboy person just but in space
where you're like just trying to get
some sheep in a in a barn but instead
you're you're just trying to get some
like metal into like this you know sort
of like I can't even describe what they
do you basically like capture these
pieces of junk and you throw them into
this this receptacle in in space that's
sort of orbiting Earth it is a very like
it is so I don't wanna say painfully but
it's like very specific to like you know
understanding how like constructions are
made and
playing a lot around with physics
because you're constantly floating in
this game as you would imagine you have
all these thrusters that allow you to to
move pretty independently but like with
a very floaty long leash kind of like
I'm gonna vacuum and I can't really do
anything precise because it's constantly
moving around like an idiot it's fun
though there is a certain attention to
detail in it that I find super
satisfying and yeah it's just a real for
me like it reminded me of outer wilds a
little bit because there's a there's
something about outer wilds that is
horrifying like I feel like people
didn't spend enough time talking about
just how [ __ ] scary that game is
because for whatever I mean like I maybe
it's a personal phobia but just like the
ocean at night the endless endlessness
of space just things that likes have no
fine I kind of end that you can first
see like give me a great deal of horror
and and this game kind of like leans
into that a little bit as well and I
just find it as horrifying as that is I
also find it to be this very real escape
from from kind of everything and it's
it's very easy to kind of get lost in
and you take on these new sort of
missions where you're you know your task
to to basically you have this like laser
gun that sort of cuts through steel and
melts joints and whatnot it's a lot of
fun and I know and I've wanted to give
it a lot more time but it's something
that I'm definitely gonna like dig into
this weekend for sure so I am very much
up to my up to my my shins in that for
sure so is it like a I guess
third-person sort of style getting the
first person's first person its first
person which I I was worried at first
goes like oh I'm gonna throw up playing
this game but yeah but no it kind of
like I think a lot of the floatiness is
is grounding in a way if that makes
sense
where you do seem to have you know once
you kind of wrap your head wrap your
head around the the basic kind of
the amount of give-and-take that you can
perform with the controls I thought I
was gonna play it's a PC game I thought
I was gonna be masking keyboard with
this thing but I found myself after like
a half hour I was like I gotta try a
controller on this one
and once I started playing with the
controller I was I was much more you
know you know had my my sort of wits
with what I could do with this game so
yeah it's it's it's a little wacky it's
in early access I have had a couple not
crashes but like situations where I had
it just like all tab and come back in
and and get my controller kind of
working again but it does perform pretty
well for the most part and I think you
know it is as as finished as you can
hope an early access game to be so so
yeah I'm definitely digging it for sure
oh that sounds awesome eight what I
guess stood out to me what you just said
was how like it's kind of chilling like
outer wilds is which is something that I
definitely got to there's something I
don't know like kind of numbing but
terrifying about being on a planet as
you see your ship flying you're like
well yeah I'm stuck here until I die and
then you just kind of wait it out and
like that I don't know that feeling was
so unique it was something that's like
really interesting to see developers
explore yeah in outer wilds like there
were so many times where I was just like
I don't know what it was maybe it was
just like not and like like losing your
point of view and not having like a
horizon to look at and you're sort of
just like you know flailing and and sort
of and tumbling in space and you're just
like what am I am I still in this game
like what what is happened am I gonna be
okay
and then like you look around is like
some sort of like gigantic piranha or
like something like yeah there was a lot
of moments in that game where I just I'm
just like I need to turn the lights on
and really step away for a second but if
the horror is not so much there in in in
this one it's just more of like that
really odd feeling of like looking down
at your planet and also at the same time
just
chillin in space which I don't know how
astronauts actually do that to me I
think like it was like oh you won't be a
nationality or like no that sounds
[ __ ] terrifying are you kidding me I
motion sickness I would not be able to
handle that [ __ ] since it's just it is
totally a wild thing but yeah I'm diggin
it um and I have actually I didn't put
it here in our rundown but I did also
dive a little into that mafia
remaster specifically mafia 2 because
that was a game I played right as I was
sort of getting into my career and it
was like one of the first events that I
attended in New York and it was like
this really cool you know introduction
to the game and it's a really good
remaster it's not just like a I mean you
know it could be like a retexture and
sort of thing I don't remember much of
the first game I just remember you know
picture what was that 2010 maybe 2018 so
long I think more like 2 is 2010 ok so
you've got like Sopranos fresh in a lot
of people's minds and like as game
definitely leans into that in a major
way but but yeah it's you know it's uh
it's it's sort of kind of dumb fun I
guess and you know I don't see myself
kind of playing through it all the way
through again but it was definitely cool
to kind of jump back into that and see
that this remaster for sure like feels
like it it holds up I didn't play the
first mafia I don't know if I have the
desire like check out what that was all
about but apparently it's tough to go
back to you today hey the first it was
it was tough to play in 2008 he played
in 2006 or 2005 that game was only like
four years old at the time and that game
was it was is very good it had it was it
was in many ways it was ahead of its
time even in the time I played in 2006
in many ways it was behind the times
like like graphically cinematically
story wise
the story beats and what they made you
do tying narrative to gameplay aspects
was like wow that game was amazing but
the shooting the actual action and the
driving the things you had to do with
the controls [ __ ] wild see what they
do it the remaster for the original
that's supposed to come out what August
or something
yeah I mafia 2 is a game that I want to
check out or I want to check out the
remaster too because I remember when
that came out I thought that game was
excellent and I didn't I don't remember
a lot of people talking about it like I
thought the story was really good I
really like the weird attention to
detail like I remember you go back to
your apartment and he's just like you'd
like I don't know call someone on the
phone or like drink a beer and hang out
as you wait for before you like turn in
for the night and begin the next chapter
of the game I don't know if that game
holds up though so it's like good
hearing back because it's a game that I
definitely want to check out again to
see if it matches how I felt and you
know whenever the hell I played it yeah
yeah I remember I remember man you know
how like all the PR pitches go but I
remember they people who who were
talking about the game we're just
talking they're like oh and I forget the
main character's name or like you go
back to your apartment and like you just
going for hear me okay okay sure why not
but yeah it's I in a couple hours I've
played I definitely found fun in it so
for sure yeah was it is it James
O'Connor as a piece on gamespot comm
cali that he revisited it and it's some
sort of analysis about how it holds up
today
it's partially about you know how does
it run it's partially about how is it
going back to this game that's on this
on what games but Game Stop games don't
stop it alright I have to check that out
pre-order that [ __ ] baby alright I mean
I guess yeah you have to I know
so I played I got to play four hours of
it
/ nvidia now which is a game streaming
thing which actually ran pretty well it
was interesting using all that stuff i
don't think many people care about that
interesting
how would you would you was it like a
shield or how did you play it so they
had me download nvidia now and then they
had me connect now actually i don't
think i connected their pc i logged in
to their account and was basically able
to run the game stream the game from my
pc in the cloud right yeah and we should
add the context of this was in lieu of a
hands-on preview videos if we go and
play the game because of a pandemic this
is their solution which is really
interesting yeah I mean I was impressed
like I there there was almost no latency
at least not that I could notice and it
looked pretty well like sure if you look
close enough you can see compression
because moving that kind of data from
one PC in Poland all the way to mine is
you know that's gonna cause some issues
but like overall it was incredibly
smooth it was also my first experience
with like game streaming because I
haven't really done that before that is
super interesting cuz like I mean they
can run it on whatever they want mm-hmm
and just stream you the you know the
video that's like that's what it is
right yeah just got the video version um
are you sure it was going overseas or
did there was nothing that they were
doing in the States like were they like
so they didn't know like I was talking
to her in Poland maybe they had like
data centers in the United States like I
guess I guess they've got a they have a
Los Angeles office and maybe someone was
out of there
but regardless like I was surprised at
how well it ran however I will say like
they sent us b-roll too and I looked
over the b-roll and I was like yeah I
can't wait until I can run this off my
hardware itself in because it's gonna
look much much much cleaner but I mean
like I guess my like high-level thoughts
are that this game seems like a
first-person GTA in a cyberpunk setting
with way more RPG mechanics and in like
the way you can develop your character
in more interesting ways than you would
in a GTA game
but like almost at the point where it
would be like alright I can hijack cars
I can drive around the city I can get in
trouble like at one point I I just
wanted to see what happened so I walked
up to a cop and stabbed him with a knife
and like I got warrants out on my arrest
this the this courtyard went into
absolute chaos people were running
around and it was just like ok this is
what happens in GTA when you do this
kind of stuff they said they're still
tweaking how exactly be the The Wanted
systems gonna work in the final release
so I don't wanna talk too much about
that but like just that initial response
after I got through the prologue and
just walked up to a cop who's I don't
know talking to some Street punk and I
was like stabbed and why not why not I
mean you know ok I gotta I gotta push it
to the limit see what happens yeah like
I don't I don't even know where to begin
like you were hours and it felt like
nothing I guess I can start with the
character creator yeah I guess I'm
curious about you can customize people
yeah
hell yeah people want to know I didn't
do it because I didn't want to spend
time in the creator
what is that labeled as this is just
pubic hair or is it like like Merkin
situation is just care ok and I actually
think I may have just been coloured to I
don't even think it was that be are you
like a little heart so they show like
junk so they didn't or they they showed
like like was egged out ok no they
should but they were wearing under it
the characters wearing underwear so I
was like I don't know maybe if I clicked
into that option I don't even know if
that implies that you're you will see
your character naked in the game
probably I'd imagine so yeah because
there's there is sex
oh there's [ __ ] Wow that's what's up
hot coffee mods you have like kind of
like GTA 2 I hate I don't keep comparing
to GTA but you have a phone not I don't
know what they call it and so just like
Animal Crossing just like Animal
Crossing you have a device we can send
you messages and this is a good way to
pick up quests like a lot of people a
lot of the text I got we're just like
hey you should check this thing out
because so-and-so is really mad about
this thing or this thing shook out maybe
you can maybe you can find some work
from here and you could just track
quests right from there so that was like
one way you could pick up quest but
they've also said previously that like
relationships are gonna be a big deal in
this game so I imagine that will play a
big role in that I'm speculating on that
part
are you expecting like I'm gonna get a
text that's like send nudes I mean oh no
didn't they say they were gonna like
we're gonna have like adult
relationships see this guy or send dudes
in case me back oh but like I didn't do
much character creation cuz I was
worried about the time except for the
skills and when you start the game you
get to invest 7 points into five
different skills which I think you're
like strength or no body reflex
technology intelligence and cool that
was six was that six no I just
miscounted I was five and depending on
what perk or what attribute you invest
in that unlocks a different set of perks
for when you start now they've talked
about this like fluid class system which
I don't know I did a video on it or I
have a video that's gonna be up on it by
the time this goes up in that I didn't
use that word because it sounded kind of
pyaari and I was like I don't use that
but yeah basically what the idea behind
that is is that you're very able to like
kind of shift course pretty quickly like
you don't need to just be a net runner
or a hacker or
a muscle or anything like that like you
can kind of pick and choose perks from
different attribute skill trees to make
your character like I played I was gonna
play more as a net runner but I quickly
realized that I was bad I was a really
bad net runner so I started investing
more into like firearm and stealth to
kind
back up my net running ability so when I
[ __ ] up which you know happened almost
every encounter I did I was able to you
know handle a gun properly and hit
people with knifes and and and and LED
pipes because I had a lead pipe that I
was using a lot
what made you a bad netrunner is the
skills you hadn't locked her like you
specifically your ability to do it so I
think it was because I think it was
partly because I didn't have a lot of
skills and partly because I would just
get spotted or I would fail the hack and
someone would notice it and they run up
to me and you know when a fight but when
I did pull it off it was pretty
satisfying because it was like early on
they do like a tutorial where you can
hack a dude and then get him to kind of
I don't know you hack whatever
I don't know electronics he's got built
into him and then another guard came
over and then you can hack the grenade
he's got so he blows up and kills them
both and like that stuff was pretty
satisfying I only got to try that out
once when I actually went into the world
like the only ability I really had was
to hack and distract other guards but
like the hacking itself seemed pretty
fun like the little minigame you do when
you're about to hack I had a lot of fun
doing I don't know if that'll get tiring
over you know dozens it's not a hundred
hours so I just feel like this is a very
tough game to like sample right to demo
yeah like how did they like how did they
like give you you know like what kind of
slice of this did you see is what I'm
really curious about like did they do
they just say like okay you've got four
hours with like three missions to like
star like how did that play out so I was
actually pretty surprised because they
they were like alright you can do
whatever you want in this game we're
gonna start you at the beginning here's
the story we recommend you do but you
don't have to do that so I didn't do any
of the story stuff other than like the
stuff that the game fed me right into
cuz
those missions they were showing mostly
had already been seen so I just explored
the world and messed around for four
hours there was no like segmented areas
they were like they they pretty much
just let me do whatever I want which was
interesting I mean I think it I feel
like very rarely developers let you do
that most of the time they like here's a
very specific part that we want you to
play and I think it does show a level of
confidence that they have with this game
to allow me to do whatever I want
because I ask multiple times I was like
are you sure you don't mind if I just
necessarily like not go for it
so I just explored the world mostly and
did like incidental quests as they
showed up but I didn't did not do much
to this story
you see Keanu I didn't see Keanu
apparently I asked him and I was like
alright so that I make a mistake if I
did the story what I was thinking like
now you wouldn't seen Keanu and I was
like dude so two more did see some story
stuff and he has a written preview up
that you can read and he talks a little
bit about one quest that gives him like
it's like a really good sign for him I
don't want to paraphrase too much I
would encourage you to read it but
talking about like the strength of CD
Projekt RED being able to inject
humanity into its worlds and how at
first two more was not seeing that
because of the kind of like weakness of
it's very edgy to like that ain't quest
is like very almost to it not to edgy
but like at times I'm like all right I
get it these like this angry badass and
Jackie likes to cuss a lot yeah which I
hated from the preview stuff I really
did not like the edgy part of that but
Tamar talked about a side quest that he
did called
losing my religion like the song I guess
that you should just read his
description I really don't want to like
paraphrase it and screw it up but it was
really promising and it made me really
excited yes so the question you're
talking about is that he talked about is
one about a I think it's a I think it's
a monk who it's against his religion to
have any cybernetic implants but gang
like some gang kidnapped him and
as are forcing implants on him and I
think you have to rescue him I didn't
play this mission but he described it to
me but it sounds pretty interesting it
sounds like a CD Projekt RED quest if
that makes sense like I've said it many
times but like the best part of The
Witcher 3 are all of the side quests all
the side quests all the monster hunts
because all that stuff is they just feel
like short the short stories that the
game was based on where you're
introduced to interesting characters
there's there's an issue usually it's
like a monster that's attacking a town
and then you investigate more and learn
that it's not just a monster like
there's something that happened along
the way like the the townspeople curse
something and they're always like very
human stories which personally has
always been my favorite part of The
Witcher so that doesn't surprise me what
tomorrow is talking about because for me
personally I bet a lot of those more
human stories are gonna come out in the
side quest once again this is
speculation but that's kind of what I'm
most looking forward to but like I said
like based on what I played I didn't get
to see a lot of those kind of quests so
I just more folk I'm gonna focus on
exploring knight City and I like got
lost in that almost instantly like
there's so like just like The Witcher 3
even like The Witcher 3 turned up to 11
the attention to detail is is absurd
like I like everything like it's so hard
to just drive through areas because
there are so many things jumping out at
you that look interesting and it's not
even like things popping up on your mat
necessarily it's just like things you
see that's like oh I want to explode
that so constantly I'm sure the guy who
is helping me max appears one of the
level designers who is like kind of
guiding me through was getting
frustrated cuz I Drive like two inches
and get out of my car like check out
this and I just like see an alley and I
check out the alley and all of us in the
alley would open up into this market
this like packed market place with all
these characters wandering around and I
and I hear him talking and and I walked
into one and there was this like I don't
know sidewalk creature who was going off
about how this generation is
ruined because all of the cybernetic
implants are destroying people's lives
and how the next generation can possibly
save it and I was sitting there watching
him just like all right I kind of want
to see what this guy has to say and
these two these two girl NPCs walked up
and they're like yeah this is the guy
this is the guy and they pulled out
their phones and started taking selfies
with them and like yeah this guy's so
crazy and just kept going and I was like
holy [ __ ] like just like just out of
nowhere this random stuff happens cuz I
was I don't know curious to see what
this guy was on about that's cool I want
to play this [ __ ] game you know what
about like the the moment a moment like
gameplay in when there's hostilities
being presented to you because when I
watch this I think of it as like a super
refined Deus Ex mankind divided type of
thing but that's a lot more fluid it has
better gunplay with laughs a bunch of
more variables at play like is it is it
that yeah I mean once again like only
playing the first four hours I feel like
I didn't really have a good opportunity
to sample all the different abilities
but in terms of the gunplay itself it
seemed pretty good like it wasn't like I
imagined a lot of people with because
people have crazy expectations for this
game and I'm sure they're going in and
spent expecting like destiny or Call of
Duty level of shooting but it's
definitely not at that like right there
is a very generous aim assist which i
think is there to kind of mitigate
how the the aiming isn't as precise as
as you know people might expect this is
this is a work in progress build so that
could change but based on what I played
the aiming seemed like it was good like
I didn't have any complaints with it but
it definitely doesn't have that
responsiveness that something like Call
of Duty or acted era destiny is is known
for
yeah sure streaming it it's tough to
know you know that's the other big thing
too and they didn't want us to play
mouse and keyboard they wanted us to
that's interesting I don't know if mouse
and keyboard would feel better so I I
don't know it's it's really hard to say
but I
we'll say like based on what I played
the shooting didn't quite feel as good
as something like that's near Call of
Duty but it felt good enough like it
definitely felt better than Deus Ex was
the last one mankind divided an
uncounseled I didn't play on PC but I've
been in console and I remember the the
gun plane that was not bad but it was
tough definitely this is definitely not
the focus of that game and yeah it seems
like that's not the focus of of
cyberpunk 27 not that I was expecting it
to be that so yeah I mean because they
do have a bunch of like they like they
were telling me there's all these
different approaches you can take to
these different scenarios like I was
saying most of the time I tried not to
shoot people I was trying to hack in and
and do stealth takedowns and stuff like
that but I mostly failed because I just
bad at it I guess so very often it would
turn into a gunfight but one thing you
can do is that first stealth takedowns
you can do you can't kill them or you
can do non-lethal takedowns so you can I
guess in theory play through the game
without killing anyone I don't know if
that means anything like what's the
difference if I die or knock them out
like is there gonna be repercussions if
I kill a guy instead of knocking Matt
are they gonna come back for me I don't
know it's hard to say yeah that's that's
like stuff that you have to after 15
hours dead no does that that's that's a
thing
well witcher 3 also it's just how and
the unforeseen consequences unfold when
you least expect it and like it happened
it's anywhere down the line 2025 hours
or whatever so now that's the true like
beauty of the CD Projekt RED i guess
yeah what's interesting though what
they're trying to do is like I feel like
the decisions you made him to Witcher
were all based in dialogue situations
while they're really trying to let
people know that the decisions you make
in dialogue dialogue situations are
important but a big thing is also the
decisions you make in gameplay and how
that could affect you I I imagine like
like I said I only messed around and did
these like side events I feel like me
killing or knocking people out probably
isn't going to matter too much in the
grand scheme of things I imagine that's
more saved for
actual like story missions where you
might be were the people you're supposed
to be killing a neutralizing might be
questionable about whether they're good
or bad right but yeah I mean it's a lot
like four hours at that game is a lot
but it's also nothing else oh yeah like
yeah I cuz there's so much I still can't
speak to I just tried to do as much as I
could and a lot of it was just getting
lost in this in this world which you
know I mean definitely works like I
could see myself spending a lot of time
just exploring nooks and crannies of
that world it's also very I don't say
overwhelming but like you walk into
certain areas and there's music blaring
there's lights flashing there's there's
the crowds are always very big there's
always lots of people walking around
that it it feels very claustrophobic
which is you know very different from
The Witcher where you've got these
wide-open areas except for novigrad I
guess which was more condensed man what
do you get what do you so what do you
guys think about like the not to derail
the conversation but I mean do you think
now with the timing of this delay like
this is being conditioned into this sort
of like next-gen launch title kind of
thing so I think I can actually speak to
this because oh great
so Figg good cuz it was it was buggy
like obviously you know that's something
that they they said would be worked out
when launching we just gotta have to
take him on their word for that but I
originally I was like I could see maybe
they delayed it just so it would kind of
line up more with next-gen consoles
right having played it I could be both
though regularly both but having played
it in like I ran into a good number of
bugs I am expecting that they are
probably taking that time to iron out
more bugs like there was one scene where
I was trying to pet a cat and the cat
just [ __ ] shot away from me as I was
having it like disappeared
I like clipped into a truck one time
because I was driving too fast and my
car
just got stuck in the truck so anyway my
internet died so we are we're back we
had a little bit of a delay right when I
mentioned glitches the internet just
shut down I think maybe CD Projekt RED
is watching somehow anyway like I did
see a good number of glitches as I was
playing and like I said it's it's not
something I want to dwell on because
they had said they're gonna work this
stuff out and you know they recently
delayed it so all we can kind of do
right now is just you know have faith
that those issues will be worked out but
yeah this game is so big that in a way
you expect there to be bugs as long as
you don't break the game right so yeah
if I see like a it's far less like I
don't say focus cuz that sounds like
this not being focus would be a negative
but it's not as I guess consequential no
yeah I mean The Witcher 3 definitely
isn't as consequential as this cuz like
you couldn't just go to a town and start
killing people because that didn't
really fit with Gerald's character so
they didn't really need to account for
that kind of stuff and you're playing as
Geralt so like sure you kind of
customized Geralt in different ways who
is but it's still Garrett you're still
swinging your sword at things and
casting like light spells well with this
you create your own character you have
different starting points which I guess
is something worth talking about and the
way you play is dramatically different
so imagine bug squashing in a game like
this is probably incredibly stressful
and incredibly difficult in requires a
lot of time yeah I don't even know how
I'm gonna go like anyone would go about
because I don't know who's gonna review
the game for us yet
um it's a little too far out to have
that lock down but just the concept of
reviewing it to me is so stressful
because it's like you can only you you
will probably only have enough time to
see like one playthrough each right
before the the embargo will lift this is
all hypothetical just based on how
reviewing games
works but like I imagine it's just gonna
be like well I played this way so I have
no idea about all these permutations
like it just seems so overwhelmingly big
and yeah look just the expanse it like
just it's intimidating it excites me a
lot I don't know if you did any of the
brain dances apparently two more did
because it happens in the story you
gotta walk there I didn't I didn't say I
didn't play any but I did see some of it
because the b-roll they sent us had
footage of the brain dances would or the
brain dance which was pretty cool which
it's basically just like a virtual
reality thing except you can manipulate
the environment more and explore and
like I don't know it was like a
detective mode in VR more or less
which was like detective it's definitely
what it felt like because there's a
character who's like handing another
character a gun and then you paused it
and zoomed in on the gun and like
scanned it and got the information about
the gun and they're like oh this is this
was this is a this kind of model and it
means that this character probably got
it from here it was all kind of scripted
in this situation they showed but still
it was just it was cool seeing that but
I think the other last big thing I do
want to talk about are the three
different life paths you can pick at the
beginning which from what we saw
dictates how the game starts so I picked
nomad and you start outside of night
city in the desert which was I thought
was pretty cool too more picked street
rat or street kid which meant his
character grew up in night City and then
I think Edie picked corpo which meant he
was like a a big I don't know a big way
get a corporation or something like that
who had a lot of influence and power and
the story still like after you get
through that the story still kind of
goes in the same direction from what we
saw but that set up is very different
your relationship that Jackie is very
different
and it seems like there are narrative
threads that the game will pull on
depending on which origin you pick which
like you were just saying right now like
that's a lot of replay value just that
alone like yeah yeah sometimes I'm
curious too to see what Jackie's
character will be like depending on what
you pick
cuz there's one version if you pick
corpo you've known Jackie your whole
life if you pick the other two you
literally just meet him for reference
Jackie's the guy who is the guy who is
helping me out and a lot of the demos
and then the other thing too is that in
last e3 they showed Jackie dying if what
it seemed like pretty early on so I
don't I'm curious to see what the deal
is with his character and what changes
depending on which life paths you pick
I'm curious if there's like one version
of Jackie that resonates with people
more than other ones but yeah yeah
that's cyberpunk I don't know that's all
I got cyberpunk sound wild man I can't
wait I can't wait I can't wait to play
it myself like even like even like what
I said earlier and when I was talking
about Deus Ex like CD Projekt RED is it
from previews like when I saw it at e3
last year it's like it's almost it's too
easy to say that they've it looks like
they put so much time and thought into
it like because of course they did but
it's it's it's a lot and I did not envy
anyone who's trying to analyze this game
because experiences are gonna be so
different across yeah or like how can
you account for maybe like some [ __ ]
that someone else saw that said said
gave a different very different message
across and other players depending on
your choices like that's such a hard
thing to account for but especially with
like trying not trying to give away too
much and you know I games like this like
I mean I'd realize it's not easy for you
know a publisher to just be like here's
what here's ten here's a hundred cop
and you know have your whole team you
know take care of it but I do think
something maybe on a smaller scale make
sense for a game like this where maybe
you have three people you know play for
as long as they can and kind of like you
know have this like hybrid kind of
conversation about it like for me you
know I probably wind up having to do
something with this game but like I
would love to hear that kind of take
from people you know from different
media companies and how they're in
outlet sand how they perceive this game
because again like such a thin vertical
slice of this seems like it's just this
insurmountable thing to convey to to an
audience so yeah that's why I think like
I don't know I guess in a weird way the
most reassuring thing about it was that
like actually playing it and realizing
that yeah this is a video game like it
like you can take that in two ways right
like a lot of people may have seen the
stuff at e3 is like smoke and mirrors
like okay well that actually like they
might be questioning if that'll actually
happen or not and then you can take it
the other way where people have like
such absurd expectations about what this
game's gonna be and like what they can
do and like I kind of had that maybe not
to the extent of a lot of people out
there but like actually playing it it
was like okay I know I know what kind of
game this is I understand it much better
than I did a couple weeks ago when I was
just kind of I don't know imagining what
it could possibly be anyway did you guys
watch this Avenger stream because I
think we should just skip it I mean it
seemed interesting I just don't know it
Sarah but Yaya can go watch that that we
have a ton of coverage on the site for
it so if you want that information it's
out there yeah however there was the
announcement of the ten cent Pokemon
collab the Polka MOBA facts Pokemon
unite which I is interesting I guess I
don't really have a lot to say about it
and don't know anything about MOBAs I'll
be curious to play it that's really all
I got I was not I mean I knew there was
gonna be a 10-cent collab it's just not
I was just not prepared I woke up her
like 5:45 like bleary-eyed like okay but
or watch this and then it started to be
a MOBA and I was like okay it's the same
I'm just sayin bad because my expertise
is not needed here they're experts to
cancel League of legendary Pokemon only
the only pun I could come up with him
was I'm popping smoke screen that's all
I had with my limited knowledge all
right so we're gonna move on to
questions I got logged out of my email
and I have to do my octet I get
information question again well first of
all we should say that you can email us
at abstract podcast at GameSpot comm or
join our discord which you can join by
emailing us at that address or DMing us
on twitter to ask us questions chat we
have an awesome community on discord so
this question is from Robert J on the
discord have you ever had to restart a
game for any reason I had to place your
Golden Sun twice because I thought I
locked myself from progressing further
because I did not get a key item which I
just recently found out was not the case
so had a blast with the game though cool
oh that's painful to hear I restart
games all the time I restart any small
mistake I make him like better restart
like I I do it less so now that I have
time limits on how long I need to like
spend playing game how long I have to
spend to finish a game but I used to
like like I've restarted kotor like no
less than 20 times in my life like i
just kept being like I love specking
characters this is what cyberpunk I'm
just gonna spend source time specking my
character and then halfway through I'm
gonna be like [ __ ] what have I done
so yeah I I I do it by choice I'm not
like I've ever restarted game based on
like a bug or a perceived bug that
wasn't a game that I was like I don't
wanna play anymore yeah things same for
me I don't think I've encountered game
breaking bugs thankfully or I've never
like accidentally saved over you know
one thing I do a lot in immersive Sims
is like [ __ ] around I then reload
its some sometimes I would get I got
like really conscious of like okay don't
say it don't save it so now what I do is
I have 30 [ __ ] save files in my list
and then I hate it when games limit how
many saves you can have yeah I'm never
gonna go back to those saves I know damn
well I'm not but I I won the Alfred I
didn't need that comfort I actually
found that I go back on saves quite a
bit with this job because it's always
like yeah well I got a capture footage I
forgot to get footage of this so it's so
when there's only like three save slots
it's like well better pick my three
slots sparingly yeah yeah but I've told
this story before but Mass Effect 3
I played 70 percent of it at launch and
then I didn't touch it again until four
years later because I've never wanted
Mass Effect to end and if I don't finish
it it doesn't end that's true
yeah and then four years later I'm like
[ __ ] it I got to do it so I did it but I
just restarted the whole thing because I
needed to get that the whole experience
all over again and like I said before
the all the DLC had come out at that
point so I was like why y'all trippin
about the ending it looks fine to me
but that's another discussion for
another time I feel like I I've
definitely done it a number of times I
don't think it's I think it's more like
if I don't finish a game like if I made
it through 75 percent of a game and then
a certain amount of time has passed
say like a year or more and I come back
to it I have to restarted yeah there's
no idea what's good no idea I have no
idea what am i what am i doing what does
this game I have to restart it
the most recent example which is not
that exact situation but after playing
Red Dead 2 on ps4
I found I tried it out on I forget what
the situation was where I I started
playing it on xbox 1x mhm and I've never
told the story before but I like
couldn't believe how much better I
thought the game looked on Xbox one x
compared to ps4 Pro and to the point
where I just started playing it again
and then like 40 hours later I was like
I'm playing this again and I'm playing
it really kind of quickly and then when
it came to PC I like restarted it again
on PC and I didn't I haven't gotten
anywhere you know as far as I did I'm on
1x but there's something about that game
that I just have no problem with with
playing over and over because it did I
you know obviously the the main story
line of missions that you play through
are are mostly the same but there is
enough variety there where it's like
even three months later it's like I knew
this feels different so so yeah it's
definitely a thing for sure I mean I've
definitely started like blood-borne over
multiple times Dark Souls just because
I'll get going with one build and I'll
be like this isn't working and then I'll
have to restart that's probably the
biggest one that comes to mind yeah next
question Michael yeah I love this
question so much I could go on and on I
can make a million video essays on it if
I wanted to but we'll do that right now
so ok so let's see what are some of your
favorite instances of amazing songs and
games that you love even more because of
when or how it occurs in the game
personal favorites love big the holy
blade from blood-borne DLC because of
how it changes during the fights life
will change from persona 5 it's one of
mine since it only plays when you're on
your way to a fight to fight a boss I
listen to both on their own but with the
added context it makes those songs even
more emotionally memorable splat Tim
from discord
I guess I should start off since I
missed a question oh go for it again too
so for persona 5 I guess the most recent
examples persona 5 royal I'm not gonna
spoil anything but when you approach the
final boss the final final boss the new
boss in royal it doesn't play life will
change it plays a song called I believe
and it is the only time that song ever
plays in the game and is probably now my
favorite song and all of the pantheon of
persona fives amazing soundtrack because
it's it takes on a difference because
life will change has a an empowering
vibe and like yeah I want to [ __ ] I
want to get up and like do some [ __ ] I
want to like I want to fight I mean
nothing can touch me you feel invincible
when you feel when you hear life its
life will change because of the context
in which it's played like you're on your
way to whoop some ass but the song I
believe it changes because it is the
it's written as a reflection of the past
100 hours of the game it is like walking
you back through all the work that you
put in to actually like try and change
the world and like brought tears in my
eyes man it's it's such an it's it's
empowering in a different way because
it's like look how far we've come and we
can't give up now
that because you you know damn well you
were about to fight one of the like the
biggest boss fight in this 120 hour jrpg
that you love so much so the context in
which it's used and the only time it's
used is very powerful the other thing I
was to say about persona 5 is rivers in
desert because that is a boss theme that
changes when you make it to the seventh
boss in the game and at that point it's
like it to me it communicates like how
tired the characters are because you've
been through so much you're just going
through so much and these you're
fighting characters who are constantly
constantly abusing their power and all
that and it's just it becomes tiring for
them to have to go through that process
over and over again but at that point
it's like the biggest boss fight and
that song is written in a way that
communicates how tired it must be to
keep
fighting these fights and then but also
kind of lifting you up in that moment
personified was just full of those
things man an undertale - we'll go okay
[Laughter]
there's a final fantasy xiv obviously
there's a bunch there that i can talk
about undertale I'll hand that over to
Kali persona 4 golden soundtracks are
the are the thing that make me remember
games so well because you will listen to
those songs way after you have played
them and you will remember exactly how
you felt and what happened in those
games so vividly most powerful thing in
games I would say it's a good snapshot
yeah undertale just is is such a
powerful example to me and I get so
excited it's so emotional I think about
undertale I really do you think of it as
like a masterpiece of a videogame and
specifically megalovania and though the
way that song weaves into how you do
that phosphite the rhythm of the music
in that game like informs how you move
within it's like it's a bullet help
precisely it was the way the comment
interface is like being in tune with the
music is such a big part of navigating I
mean that fight took me two weeks I
played every single night for two weeks
and is one of the hardest things I've
ever done in any video game and
finishing it was like was unreal like an
unrivaled experience when I hear
megalovania it's like all of that it's
like those two weeks of like I had
already done a pacifist run I'm doing my
genocide run like that whole run is an
emotional roller coaster and then you
get to that final fight and then for to
be stuck on it for two weeks and had not
know how the game ends or how that that
run ins that all comes flooding back
when I hear that song I would say so
that's the most powerful example
specifically with how this question is
worded I also really like the way music
is used
stranding and creating like this like
lonely like almost like I'm looking at
the window on a road trip and I'm
depressed kind of feeling and I really
like the music the music choice in that
game and I love hotline Miami's music
and puts another example of getting into
the rhythm with the music really helps
with the action and I listen to the
hotline Miami soundtrack all the time
especially if I'm like really trying to
focus and like get [ __ ] done and I like
puts me in a certain mood and finally
halos music as a series makes me very
emotional I'm not even exactly sure why
but some of the like really epic tracks
when you're like doing warthog runs or
whatever I'm just like this is the best
experience I've ever felt so yeah but
undertale I think it's just a superb
example especially because it's so
cohesive with how Toby Fox wrote that
music
he made the game he did have some help
but like you really feel how it all
weeps together and I do think of it as
being especially when it was released
unparalleled in the way whoa gameplay
mechanics with story in such an expert
way I guess for me like I'll keep it
short but the one that comes to mind is
far away that song in Red Dead
Redemption when you cross over to Mexico
I remembered that moment a lot of people
talk about how cool that moment is but
that song too in particular is just like
so perfect for what's happening and I
and I even like would extend that to how
Red Dead Redemption to use as music I
think it works really well like the song
unshaken gives me chills having you know
finished that game a couple times and
yeah like the Red Dead music just the
way all that plays out is really good
and on top of that man last of us is
music stands out to both the first and
the second I really like like I mean
last was two uses of Pearl Jam song
big Pearl Jam fans so seeing that was
like very exciting but also it added so
much more meaning to that song that
originally wasn't there I was surprised
how much of a lasting effect the sort of
like sad bastard covers were in that
game like the take on me and everything
yeah right like I I just that's I don't
know like I was I was like why am I am i
tearing up at this like what's going on
I don't know like I just had this yeah I
don't know been crying a lot with games
like other things though that maybe it's
like I don't know being I'm not a new
dad but like I don't know it's yeah it's
just coming to terms okay so a lot of
stuff but like yeah I would definitely
echo last of us too for sure I didn't
want to cut you off Jake but like
there's a lot of really good score stuff
you know I forget who composed all the
Christopher Nolan's stuff for princess
yeah but it's like I should know I
listen to that soundtrack a lot like
there's so many of those like like
really effective like I I thought that
was going to be a cinematic like fad
that would just sort of you know
evaporate after a couple years but like
that [ __ ] is still super effective and
conveying like this very you know
upsetting kind of tension but yeah oh if
I could say one more thing please one
more thing about persona 5 this is how I
closed out my p5 our review which is to
me is why music is so powerful is that
there's so there's a song called Sunset
Bridge and it plays any time characters
have a revelation I say this is my
review and it's kind of like oh it's
this this kind of calming but
bittersweet moment where people realize
that like who they are what their places
in the world that song plays on the
final day of the game when you have to
say goodbye to everyone and I had a very
hard time listening to that song because
I loved listening that soundtrack to
straight-up
like oh [ __ ] I'm just gonna jam out but
I always skipped that song because it it
hurts too much to listen to it because
it reminded me of that moment when I had
to say goodbye to all my friends on the
final day of that game and it did it it
[ __ ] again in persona 5 royal and I
was just like god damn it it's such a
it's such a like well composed song and
it just I say it's better a bittersweet
there's no words to it there's nothing
that's being said to you but the
instrumentation does all the
communicating for that and it is one of
the one of the most like the it is one
of my most memorable moments probably my
most memorable moment playing a game is
like when that [ __ ] hit me like oh [ __ ]
this is my moment this is my revelatory
moment and realizing my role in this
game so that's the power of music bro
music doesn't more I fit for me
personally then than any other kind of
like visual thing like even in like the
evil with like clair de lune is one of
my favorite pieces of music and the you
know those like checkpoint II parts in
the evil within with the mirror and they
play that that that piece and it's just
like I don't know what it is but I am
such a sucker for that for that you know
arrangement it's just like if that's
playing you have my attention
and whatever you're doing is important
you know the first level and I came is
clair de lune oh no I have not played I
love the game but there is one song in
particular is that I just absolutely
adored in the way that level there's
like this crescendo to it and and I
wanted to bring up more of a rhythm
music kinks we didn't really talk about
those I think maybe it's that's a whole
other conversation yeah clearly and just
reminded me I love clearly I love it
it's awesome well I think that's episode
47 of GameSpot after dark thank you all
so much for joining and thank you Jeff
fer I know it's sent us a bit later for
you but officially it's been fun it's
all good thank you so much for having me
and let me spend in time with everybody
this was a lot of fun for sure
of course this is great it's great
episode if you've got any questions for
us you can send them to after dark
podcast at GameSpot calm or you can join
the discord and you can just DM us on
Twitter or email us email that email and
we'll get you into discord and you can
ask questions there Michael quickly got
anything you're working on this week
that you want to I I follow you I'm
doing a lot of stuff that's under
embargo at the moment so I can't talk
about that but I've been doing a [ __ ]
ton of play for all interviews and you
can everyone's been putting in so much
work for play for all we got a lot of
stuff going up now and we have a lot of
stuff planned for the future so check
all that stuff out but if you want to
find me you can find me and all of my
[ __ ] at Michael P hi I'm on Twitter
oh boy my timeline is [ __ ] wild you
want games you want political this
course you want emo [ __ ] how long all
that you want all of you know Josiah I
feel bad for the people who follow me
but I love you all appreciate y'all for
me there's just a bunch of cyber stuff
cyberpunk stuff that's probably already
up by now in fact it should be by now so
check that stuff found there's more
stuff coming out over the weekend yeah
Oh add Jacob deck County how are you if
you want to see a spicy Twitter timeline
account for you you can follow me on
twitter at a keto jacob i NK why DOJ I
can't can't oh I've been going hard um
but I I'm doing doing good and as always
I would humbly request that she read
games books reviews as that is I'm kind
of on my own Island I haven't done a lot
of play for all stuff I don't really
have a lot besides The Last of Us
if you're finishing The Last of Us it
would mean a lot to me if you checked
out the spoiler review I put a lot of
work into that and I am in our spoiler
chat where we talk about our
interpretation of the ending so we have
a lot of Alaska stuff that that would be
awesome
but yeah I you know I'm just I'm now on
don't suppose come on I suppose and
onward enough they're back on your
[ __ ] yeah are you Jeff
my Twitter is not as spicy but I have a
five year old talking about bug snacks
so if you're into that good
my Twitter handle is at Jeff Bakalar
yeah and if you are interested in the
wonderful world the pinball you can
follow me and I try and stream couple
times a month so I would love for you to
join me if that's something you'd be
interested in and yeah check out the the
giant beast cast if you have not already
and that goes up why we do it live so
it's just up after it's live now so it's
like what is that like Thursday
afternoons on the time so yeah I
remember we can about waking up Friday
mornings new beast cast let's go you
guys are wonderful I love the beast
casts one of my favorite podcasts man
approve any Abbi Alex are wonderful
people that look it's not true for all
of us but yes I would agree yeah these
videos are our podcast dad he has a very
comforting presence so and I appreciate
that for sure he's just you walk into
his house and it's just the microphones
and mixers everywhere woodwork and game
would break he is grandpa podcast
version ham ham radios anyway that's one
episode 47 we'll see you all next week
[Music]